des idées des prix des spécialités
laisser tenter par quelques questions et
nous rions pour parfaire mon billet là
jamais mangé personne mais quand
germaine n'assister pas envie que ça ne
m'intéresse pas relais moi je viens je
me promène je fais du lèche vitrine
c'est gentil ça mais c'est pas drôle
tous elle ne suis pas pour rigoler avant
la zone des supporters pénitents non
seulement on m'avait dit que ça existait
mais je voulais me rendre compte par moi
même tu as raison c'est plus marrant que
par correspondance
toute cette misère sexuelle
c'est cet effrayant raconte tous ces
gens qui rôdent la langue pendante en
bavant de concupiscence coeur un seuil
et du passage tous et cette chaussée
pitcho ces rapports
j'aimerais que monsieur visiter le
quartier à fond 1
en plus je suis sûr que ça vaut la peau
des fesses non ça n'est pas en quoi les
petits rôles à l'aller pauvres et le
petit jeu ça va chercher dans les
combien la forte elle était sympa oui
non c'est ce qu'on va voir si étroits
que je vais raquer la poule est il grand
jeu ça va
aubin c'est le dos de la forcément
olalalala est alors pour ceux qui
viennent plusieurs fois par semaine ça
monte un oui ben je sais pas vous faites
des abonnements mais quoi des tarifs
dégressifs des facilités de paiement
non mais plein tarif oui en liquide ma
mère me vous rendez compte
alors quelqu'un je sais pas moi
quelqu'un qui vient admettons le bon une
moyenne de 5,6 fois par semaine on
dépose ans a lui fait c'est lui la
réunion c'est ça faire un vallée matta
caisse enregistreuse non tu mon trottoir
une grande surface et moi pour une boîte
de cassoulet là
ben quoi je suis un consommateur
responsable - madame je m'occupe de
vérifier le rapport qualité prix
oui tu cherches un homme d'excès ou quoi
non mais dis donc j'ai jamais une
réclamation moi je te le dis alors vous
êtes devant la t2 que ceux dont une
facture avec la tva mans bah quoi vous
êtes un petit commerce avec l'union sur
rue qui me plaît mais oui parce que moi
j'en fais travail du bon tiens on va
commencer par les cordonniers et avec
tout ce que je balance à de l'or là
alors vous êtes taxé comme un produit de
luxe ou produits de première nécessité
première nécessité je suis d'utilité
publique monsieur comme la croix rouge
tient faut faire nationalisée merci bien
on retrouve au chômage technique
on a goûté du moment cocasse pour votre
outil de travail voire simone il en
coûte assez cher
enfin l'un dans l'autre vous arriver à
équilibrer votre balance des paiements
sayah autant qu'ils rendent une
authentique non mais parce que vous
venez vous avez vous avez un joli
capital
joli petit fond de commerce
en faudrait pas gâcher faut investir
mais je demande que ça moi m'investis
non investir dans la pierre les studios
les garages les boks ah oui tiens ça me
rappelle mes débuts
enfin ça évidemment pour ça faut
quelqu'un qui s'y connaît ce coin
remarquer moi j'ai bien réussi à assurer
mes arrières
ah oui et tu voudrais tarifs et des
mines je demanderai pas mieux je
pourrais gérer votre portefeuille comme
ça vous auriez les mains libres pour
jouir de vos ressources
puis je vous ferai jouer en bourse ça me
coûterait combien de sa part de ça
évidemment au départ la mise de fonds
faut compter 50 % de vos gains quoi webb
a dit l'hôte est un dur tout arranger
une pitié pour autant oui seulement moi
je vous fais faire la culbute
mais alors faut voir je dis pas non
ouais ben c'est une affaire qu'on
pourrait essayer de conclure assez
rapidement na utile dans this way
seulement il ya une chose moi avant de
me lancer j'aimerais quand même bien
savoir si l'affairé cen et baronnies
vassy voix et voilà ça va me coûter un
rouge